foreign
Asheville North Carolina hi John how are
you
I'm good how are you better than I
deserve how can I help
so
um I'm in a situation
um it's a lot of debt and I was I'll
just start running the numbers by you
um so I'm a first year physical therapy
student I still have two more years to
go of schooling I myself am in 78 000 of
debt
um my fiance and soon to be wife is in
20 through Sally May 220 000.
um and also another 88 000 through uh
FAFSA student loans so
totaling all that up it's about 400k ish
um
what's she studying
she just finished physical therapy
school
um she's been working now for two months
she just started working in June
um you spent wait a minute she spent 200
000 dollars
and another 88. she spent 300 000 on a
PT degree why I
I know and for the longest time in our
relationship
um
I had school choice I mean what was the
deal no it's I mean it was it was a
state school
um up in Pennsylvania
um but
I don't think her family has much they
have five kids and I know they recently
just got out of debt to my knowledge
um okay so she's gotten her first job
what's she making 80
she's making 74 before taxes is she
gonna is she
is she that earns more than the average
the only thing she could do is get a
travel job which tend to pay closer to
if you would extrapolate it out closer
to 100K a year 90 to 100K a year however
with me being in school in Asheville for
the next two years approximately when
are you getting married um
or getting married in December good okay
all right well I mean the the the the
thing you do John is the ratio you're
looking at is and this is this reason we
ask these questions every time is
um if you get out you're making 75 she's
making 75 that's 150 and you're gonna
have 400.
so that's the shovel to Hole ratio we
always call it in other words your
shovels your income the hole is 400
right
right okay so how quick do you pay off
400 making 150 well if you live on 50
and you put 100 to four years
right
that's how we do it I mean that's how we
run the math there's just big numbers
like that because we don't ever we
always want to assume you live on
nothing and you put everything I mean if
you could live on 30 and put 120 it cuts
it down by a few months you know but uh
and you pick up some OT which both of
you can do pick up some emergency fund
emergency room
um and anything else you can pick up
that's not travel right but um she can
make another 20 working OT working some
overtime for somebody
um it's out it's available and um and it
it can be done and then you just plow
your way through it I mean if you guys
get if both of you make 90 instead of
making 75 or both of you make 95 instead
of making 75 when you get out then
that's how you're going to plow through
it but it's going to be a because you're
not getting out for another 18 months
after marriage or so it's gonna be a
long slog I mean y'all y'all got a three
four year at least four-year program
of no life don't talk about buying a
house
don't talk about going on vacation all I
want you to talk about is how much
you're going to work and how little
you're going to spend
because the more of that you do the
faster you get out and the higher the
probability is that you do get out
because otherwise you're going to look
up 20 years from now and you're still
going to be sitting on that egg trying
to hatch it and that's my biggest
takeaway for you John don't don't let
the magnitude of this cause you to not
start because the time is going to pass
anyway and you're going to look up in
five years and five years from now or
four years from now you're either going
to look up and this is going to be a
gone thing of the past that you used to
know or you're going to be smack dab
right in the middle of it and some of it
will have gone up do you see what I'm
saying you got to take everything you
can get on income and cut every expense
you can cut on outgo
and I mean we're talking beans and rice
rice and beans ramen noodles Tuna fishes
for broke people I mean this is what
you're broke people that's what you're
getting into it's what you're signing up
for and both of you have signed up for
it so yeah and I I wouldn't tell you to
do anything other than that I mean get
married in December and then start
working it as hard as you can work it
and you know who's paying for the
wedding
um we collectively as a couple are going
to pay
um probably a little under 10 grand and
then both families have agreed to pay
approximately 10 grand each okay that's
a nice wedding yeah okay and no you're
not going in debt for it so that's good
yeah no more debt and don't tell me you
got to buy a car and don't tell me you
got to buy a house you're broke people
with lots of degrees yep and you got to
clean the mess up man I mean you got to
re-identify yourself in your mind and go
okay I got to clean this up I got to
clean this up I got to clean this up and
you just get in that mode and you can do
it you can do people do it all the time
Jay did it you paid off again and it
took me longer than you John so you can
do it you can do it yeah
yeah but you started with a lot less
income that is awesome at the beginning
of it but um y'all paid off 460
something almost 500 yeah that's right
total of which almost 300 was student
loans that's right it can be done it's a
slog but put those milestones in there
build it in when we get once we pay off
this amount we're going to do this thing
once we pay off this amount we're going
to do this thing you don't it's not
enough to get yourself off track but you
have to celebrate those Milestones
especially when you're in it for more
than two three years you've got to keep
yourself motivated by doing that and if
it makes you feel better you can be one
of those idiots that post on the
internet Dave Ramsey won't let me have a
life
I've seen some of those Dave because
it's not Dave Ramsey it's you yeah
yeah you get to the side I'm not gonna
do it Dave Ramsey just told you how to
get out Jay just told you how to get out
you could actually post Jade told me I
can't have a life no no no no it's it's
till Dave do us part not till Jade do us
part whoa come on
you can throw me out of the bus You're
Gonna Leave Me by myself on the mean
internet memes
I don't know Dave I don't know if I can
handle it I'm thinking I think you ought
to get I think they ought to come on you
guys put it out there jade made me do it
Jade ruined my life
is this because you didn't get the the
slash Jade the slash no one it's I'm
still bitter you're right you're
bringing up stuff from five weeks ago
but I'm still bitter
but yeah the the thing is I didn't ruin
anybody's life I just told you to go
ruin your own life so you could get your
life back because you sold it to Sally
May you sold your butt to Sally Mae you
signed the deed to your butt and you
handed your deeded butt over to Sallie
Mae and now you got to get your butt out
of Hawk yeah and that's what it amounts
to and it's a pain in the butt to do it
it's not easy a lot of butts going on
here a lot yeah you put them in there
but it's not the point is
the point is there's nothing easy about
this you can try to look for a a
loophole or an easier way out but when
you've got this kind of that you have to
sacrifice to win there's no no two ways
about it and the weird thing guys for
everybody out there John included
congratulations on the December wedding
uh we just signed you up for hell uh not
the marriage but the uh the process of
getting out of debt there afterwards but
yeah but the uh for everybody John
included the interesting
thing is
what happens inside of your spirit while
you're fighting through this Bingo Jade
and Sam
are a power couple to be reckoned with
they probably would have become that
anyway but they became that more so by
fighting this fight the transformation
and the calluses that happen
in your character that cause you to be
able to hold your breath grit your teeth
and push through hell and get it cleaned
up set the stage for you to be able to
tackle anything after that yeah you
can't you can't get between us and at
this point there's nothing there's
nothing you can tell me that I'm gonna
go I don't know if I can do that it just
builds this muscle of belief of it's
like when a woman has a baby you can't
tell her nothing after that it's like I
can do anything and it's the same way
when you pay off this debt you can't
tell anybody nothing after they pay off
460 000 a day exactly exactly and that's
what it's going to do but but it the the
force that causes that piece of coal to
become a diamond is this extreme
sacrifice in a short period of time and
it causes not only the debt to go away
but a wonderful permanent change in your
relationships and in your life that's
the beauty of it so embrace the suck man
lean into it